I am here recording at the J.C.C. Center Lines special needs fair, my name is Diane Campione
recording for visible lives. I'm sitting here with Jeanette Solomon. Hi Jeanette, who are you
speaking about today? I'm speaking about my daughter Lana. And learn attends what school?
?Wrinkles? high school
Tell me what made you suspect that Lana was different? When she born, she had
medical and health issues from the start. So they thought it was genetic.
She was very sickly, ?inaudible?
she had ?inaudible?, but when time came the medical issues
got better and they ended up diagnosing
her on the autism spectrum. And at what age was that?
At about 16 months. Tell me about the day Lona was diagnosed.
.
What was that like?
Well it was more of a relief to get a diagnosis, I finally have a name
To say she had something, so we could get a treatment plan. Because I was starting from
not knowing. So every day I was living in fear of not knowing. They kept talking medical
reasons she had this. I thought, I thought
it was more of a relief when I knew what it was and then I
knew what we could do to help it. And what was her
classification? they classified her autism. They started off P.D.D
started of you know, they put her in right away, 20 hours of  A.D.A therapy
?inaudible?, speech, O.T and P.T, so our days were basically
Mondays through Fridays, therapies all day long.
How would you describe your emotions after the initial diagnosis?
.
Probably from the shock for a while of everything I had to do. It felt like
my whole life just revolved around her, and I really didn't get a break to probably
think too much, so I really ran on autopilot, I think for the first year
or 2 with her.
And what word you say best describes the difficult stages of Lona's
disability ?
Probably between the ages of 4 and 8
when we were working on body training, and it wasn't going well, we had a lot of
of a, smearing incidents as we would call it, and that went on for quite a few years
so, very difficult times. And any time I took her anywhere she would get very nervous
and throw up. (Chuckles) So I was living between
one mess to another mess not matter where I was. And what would you say the biggerest
obsticcal was to overcome. Well she's Non-verbal. So, Communication.
Once we started to work on a device, and getting her to be able to tell us
her needs, her behaviors got so much better.
So probably between 10 and up it went -it just skyrocketed.
Her behaviors got so much better.
Because now she could tell us what she wanted, how she felt.
She's typing now you know telling us her needs and her wants.
So... its been a relief since
You know. Do you ever feel as they gave up your life to get a Lona
a life? Well I never went back to work,
so basically I have, my
life has been revolved around her, and helping her and and I got involved with
her school, so I can be involved and know what's going on, and help all the kids more
So that's my life. I've been volunteering and advocating.
Do you ever did you ever ask why?
I did, I questioned it. You know, I got mad. I had anger issues in between. You know, why
me, why me? You know, something I just learned it's
what I have and I just have to deal with it and make the best of it. And you know what
been easy, and once I accepted that fact it made it easier for me.
.
Is there something that you would like the public to know that individuals with autism?
I think a lot of known individuals with autism ,
communication is one of their hardest issues and if you can break through that barrier, you know
it's much easier for them, and they can do so much
more than you ever though. That's what I have seen: just so much more than I ever believed
doing now.
Absolutely. Can you finish this sentence for me. I draw my strength from
.
I draw my strength from my daughter, and watching her go through her struggles and her accompishments.
I really do, and seeing how strong of a person she is has made me strong.
Your story is inspiring and I want to thank you for sharing her story with me.
Thank you for taking the time to be interviewed it's going to be an important fact that the
public know that, individuals like this and and because of you I feel much more
educated. Thank you so much.